they let her continue doing anything
after she pointed a gun at people I mean
at this point everybody wants to go
along with the best she actually got a
she got a cooler it was a big yes and
cry yes stick around
guys you should never have to compromise
on Comfort Helix has mattresses with
cooling technology that helps regulate
your body temperature whatever the
season by supporting Helix you are
allowing them to support us in our show
go purchase your Helix and thank us
later for the best night's sleep of your
life yes and Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners so go to Helix
sleep.com slash DPT use the code Helix
partner 20. this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now thank you to our
sponsor Verity farades a family brand
founded by Alex his wife Carrie and his
twin brother Mike that channels their
love of beach lifestyle into clothing
for life's greatest moments Verity
crafts clothes guys that feel as good as
a day at the beach and they're back by
their guarantee of quality Verity is
giving all dumb people Town listeners an
amazing deal 20 off on your order head
to ferritybrand.com DPT use the code DPT
at checkout for 20 off your order that's
fah e r t y brand.com slash DPT hey we
want to give a shout out and say thank
you to our sponsor prize picks prize
picks is the most fun we've had winning
up to 25 times our money this football
season all you have to do is select two
or more players pick more or less their
projected stats and place your entry go
to prize picks.com slash d p t that's
crucial and use code d p t extra crucial
so you can get your first deposit match
up to one hundred dollars that's
prizepix.com DPT use the code DPT for a
first deposit match up to 100 promo
codes all lower case prize picks daily
fantasy sports Made Easy nice hey
townies welcome to another episode of
dumb people Town population
Wayne David Wayne Master rack on tour
Storyteller comedian actor director
father friend friend friend for a long
time friend number one put that first I
put it last because it's the most
important so it is amazing what's up
townies yeah let's get started also uh
when everything comes back and there's
no strike potential uh director of a
Cleveland balloon movie yes so we are
doing a patreon that was the funniest
response to that and we texted
um David because he's from Cleveland
from Shaker Heights that's right Shaker
Heights right so we aren't promoting a
thing for everybody because it's not
real it's not real yet but I do want
that movie to come out and I want you to
I love that story and I'm ready
because it's the audacity and no
forethought right that's what makes
great comedy the confidence and the
failure so 80s it felt like uh it was a
radio promotion type thing my only
concern is if we wanted on when we shoot
if we want to start at eight I'm that
first day I have something so that's
fine
just set it up and then I can do a
little bit A.D yeah I can be there like
8 15. we'll have the ad set the first
shot and then you can just come in and
look at it can we go just check the gate
he's going to do it
the first Studio Movie I did direct was
Role Models yes and I remember one day I
was driving up to uh Santa Clarita where
we were shooting this big giant battle
scene and I took the wrong turn and it
was also like weather and raining and so
and I ended up being like a half hour
late but I'm usually like an hour early
yeah yeah yeah and I was so embarrassed
like where's David just figured out they
don't have an 18 GTA on no and meanwhile
you cared probably a lot more than
everyone else because work was getting
done and they were all getting in yeah
but yeah it's not a good I know but yes
ultimately ultimately you did the day
but also proves that we it we consider
ourselves to be smart people but we do
dumb things which is a perfect and also
we consider ourselves to be
indispensable but things get done
exactly exactly when we did our show um
medical police I actually was sick
during part of it and I had to leave the
set a couple times early in the
afternoon and I was like at that point
in my life I had grown up a little bit
and I was like whatever nobody cares
do you remember when I threw up on the
set of Children's Hospital the one you
directed with oh yeah so there's the
Cutaway shot of me and like for 12
minutes as I'm waiting for them to cut
to me the whole bit was that Randy was
in the show and he had to do this
complicated thing where they were
shooting him twice meanwhile I'm just
watching in the wings and they could
have used me but they need to get the
Cutaway of me watching the wings and I
start to feel like oh I'm gonna go down
yeah I have to hold it together so they
get the shot because it's the whole show
and also you don't want to be sick
honestly you don't want to sick on the
show you just want to be you want that
time where the flu shot through the
whole set yeah it did yeah I remember
like but I wasn't first I didn't give it
to everyone someone else had it they
think that's what somebody says it's
going to give it to everybody no but so
they get my cutaway shot and then
literally you're like okay you're like
that's great cut and I'm like oh God
yeah yeah all over stay on them stay on
them stay on him get it I remember that
those that was like a day and a half on
set where every time I turned around
another crew member was throwing up in a
garbage can it was like of course these
days I think people would probably leave
I felt so bad I drove right away but I
felt horrible shall we
it's so relevant I have to say one of
the things the other night at this show
that you were in that I know I think you
will be talking about the middle aged
jam band amazing our uh keyboard guitar
player singer he got sick came up to me
in the middle of the set right before he
was about to sing his song and said
David I'm sick I have to go and he left
and he went and threw up yeah and then
he came back like three times later and
finished the shows with an amazing piano
solo in that song at the end but he was
in The Green Room and we're like so all
of us are like what do you need can we
get you because we're all dads because
we're dead I mean for me I'm like yeah
whatever you know but like I know that
as when you're you know it's it's like
our show business like you just do it
unless you play yeah that's the thing
when someone gives you no explanation
that's how severe it is right when
they're like I am leaving right now
you're like okay whatever you do
whatever you got to do well and later he
was like thanks for being so cool about
it I'm like what was I gonna say like no
you stay there yeah
you've seen those YouTubes of the kid
drumming in the I don't know if you have
in like an orchestra and then he throws
it's like in the at the end of a big
drum solo yeah it just finishes it as
he's calming down he's like
it's so great all right the first sorry
star number one sent in by and I I don't
know if we've ever had these person or
group of people send in this is it makes
me so happy because I think it's a fake
company sent in by Deco resources at
Deco underscore resources so this is
either a fake company or it's a real
company and this person is using company
kind of great to make your burner
account seem like a business right Deco
resource that's a big thing you know you
can you can make an account that's like
U.S tax collecting yes especially now
yeah dude when we drive on the young
people and be like hey you owe us 35
bucks okay I would call my if I was
making a fake company system services so
it's great right but there's a whole
thing also where you can just you can
you can get any email address or website
and so you can say like you know
Jennifer Lopez assistant gmail.com 100
and then easily get a reservation that's
right you email the hotel ahead of you
coming and then this is not my thing
because Jennifer Lopez happens to be a
close friend very close you're her
assistant and my assistant will you
remember her when she was Jenny From the
Block and he actually calls her logo and
at that time I was her assistant and now
she's my assistant that's been wonderful
she full circle she took davidwayne
assistant at gmail.com that's her email
it's her email all right you ready yes
here's the headline Story number one
exotic cat rescued from Tree in Ohio
test positive for cocaine
the tree the tree did not the Exotic cat
which was rescued from a tree nuts don't
need coke cats to me are already on
cocaine right you ever if you are
dealing act like you have a
responsibility to keep the drugs away
from your pets or your exotic cat I
think I can speak with a little more
expertise on this having been born and
grown up in Ohio this is why we did this
story and in Ohio cats are very similar
to where they are in other states
there's no difference whatsoever but I
can just confirm that thank you for that
we needed someone on the hands yeah
thank you thank you thank you what is it
like a cocaine Bearer situation yeah it
is this could be the next episode the
Exotic cat known as the serval cat oh
those are huge big cats
doesn't Mary Lynn have a
she has a giant cat I'm like why do you
need a serval cat I'm gonna I'm gonna
confront I wish my cat was more servile
thank you there you go folks the Exotic
cat Noir
no we're keeping it in tested positive
for cocaine after having a meeting with
director Elizabeth Banks is that weird
yeah that's strange that no uh after
being rescued in Cincinnati I know it's
not Cleveland but we can still not even
close not even close it's like according
to animal control this is why people
shouldn't have this whole story time and
trees and Dew in Coke and Cincinnati I
love that show Servals are immediate
they say medium-sized Wildcats native to
sub-Saharan Africa meaning don't put
them in Ohio right well I mean that is
the southern tip of Ohio so I understand
so is that sub the saharans I mean it's
right on the border of Kentucky so right
it's a very accurate uh it's Saharan
Ohio no shade on Cincy but my God
uh the serval named Emery okay a-m-i-r-y
which to me I I've said this on the show
one of my favorite things to do is when
my daughter was in uh gymnastics was to
just write down in my the notes section
of my phone the name of every kid who
was in the gymnastics competition and
then when my wife and I were having a
down moment later I would just pull it
out and just start reading the names
that's Emory
yeah it's also where we booked our
daughter's birthday party yeah yeah was
rescued at the end of January after
escaping from a vehicle during a police
stop and climbing a tree so clearly on
new cat's like I'm coked up if these
cops are coming in here I better get the
[__] out of here by the way that's what
someone on coke would do if they can't
yeah if you had stories where they uh
like you know man in a tree yeah drunk
stuck in a tree like so it's just the
cat he didn't want to come down because
his girlfriend broke up with him was
that it I know it sounds right I just
don't know how cats where they get the
money for this I know exactly like who's
he getting his cocaine from or she uh
which responded to the incident Ray
Anderson the show today
I don't know uh the shelter's community
engagement manager told CNN that the
cat's owner had been pulled up CNN
pulled over by the police for an
unrelated traffic well they didn't tell
CNN they told Don we're talking about
it's like I don't work here cat News
Network
all your cat news yeah save that idea
please save that idea this is it's like
mail that to yourself that news network
is counter programming to the public
that would be a project to bring to
Dabney
I'm gonna give him a call give him a
call rest in peace and I know he's not
dead I just told the cat News Network
that the cat's owner and so if you have
a coked up serval cat in your car maybe
drive safer don't don't run a stop sign
s-t-o-p I would check that the claws are
clipped as well yeah Hamilton County dog
Wardens what are we bringing a dog
warden in it they hate cats a division
of Cincinnati Animal Care work to
retrieve the quote highly agitated
highly upset serval from the tree I'm
sure that was fun this is not like
getting a tabby guys this is like
getting a mountain lion that is coked up
down from a tree I know that growing up
in Ohio the Cincinnati Animal Care
whole department is corrupt and
basically it's a it's a population it's
like Cop Land isn't it it's every
everyone's taken from everyone else
that's on the take I mean I've seen so
much evidence just disappear from these
guys
I've seen them you know what I've seen
them plant Coke on a dog I've also seen
them take a see a stray dog with disease
and look the other way because they were
taking it from the rabies people that's
right the rabies racket is insane in
Ohio
they took a sample for a DNA test uh and
also test them for Narcotics and after
getting the DNA why would you test
suspicious of it so they test the DNA
and they solve three cold cases
what are you doing 23andMe on a cat food
I know right drug testing uh rescue
animals is a fairly new procedure for
the shelter according to the a Facebook
post so you know it's true I guess it
would help you explain some of the
behavior if you had an animal you're
giving an animal uh like like class one
narcotics or maybe the maybe maybe the
cat was about to do a bike race yeah and
they needed a drug test it's just doping
he's like these oxygen levels are insane
these owners like sniff this and come up
with three new business ideas right so
they started regularly testing exotic
animals for Narcotics after an incident
last year Where They seized a Capuchin
monkey uh named Neo who tested positive
for methamphetamine well there's the
movie right there
monkey monkey
we're two in we've already got cocaine
bear that monkey is as good as cocaine
bear I think cocaine cat is the short
before meth monkey cooking right exactly
like the pictures are short yeah the
animated short the testing confirmed
that Anne-Marie was indeed a serval
which are illegal to own in the state of
Ohio you know that and that he'd been
exposed to cocaine Anderson told the cat
News Network that the shelter was unable
to disclose how much cocaine Emery had
again because they went and did the rest
of it you know these yeah oh yeah I
don't trust them I don't trust them Coke
around the investigation is ongoing I
didn't know that was illegal in Ohio
because I actually as someone who grew
up in Ohio I do read through the legal
code each year but I'm not I didn't get
to the end when you do that every
Christmas Eve yeah sometimes I just skip
to the changes yeah well that's why you
do it at Christmas
and a Google doc with track changes yeah
and you Redline it and then send it back
to them which is my thoughts which they
always ignore I think I think we can
tighten up this law so they always
ignore it but they always send you an
email saying we appreciate what you've
done yeah thank you I love what you have
here here's a few notes yeah in the
Facebook post the shelter said amory's
owner cooperated with the investigation
and relinquished the cat into the
shelter's custody his honor was
cooperative and paid for Emery's care
until all ownership transfers were
finalized which is when this story went
public the Wildcat is now under the care
of the Cincinnati Zoo which we all know
Dan you you're all a bit about zoos we
don't need to have zoos anymore no need
for Zeus right it's just a place to walk
your kids around that's right wait a
minute then what do we what do we
replace them with just leave them as a
park let the kids play in the polar bear
moat but like we don't need zoos you
know what a polar bears Zeus were
invented so like prove to people in
Illinois that a zebra was real right and
we've gotten past that your zoo is on
your phone we don't need this anymore
but what if we want to see uh zebra
in Cincinnati Checkmate I'm playing uh
yeah
we got you Dan he got you that is the
greatest Devil's Advocate I mean just
repeat a fact that you gave me with a
question mark what if I want to see a
zebron bath salts huh what am I gonna do
then where am I going to see that
Wildcats down to the care of the
Cincinnati Zoo recording Facebook post
and a blog post on Wednesday the zoo
said that Emery is eating well moving
around his new habitat indoors and
outside and keeps asking the other
animals for money
let's pitch the other animals I'm gonna
get you back five business ideas will
definitely succeed I wonder what um my
how my SeaWorld stock is doing
is it is it plummeting or how's it doing
I don't know I check it every day
how many sea worlds are left is it just
San Diego
Orlando is black what was the oh yeah
yeah killer whales yeah
I used to go to the one that was near
Key Biscayne Florida all the time that
Sea World down there we've been to the
one in San Diego many times yeah
I don't want to go back exactly we saw
it we still saw it all right there you
go that's Story one down in the books we
come back we'll find out uh Jay and I
participated in one of my favorite shows
that we've done recently with uh David
and he's taking it out on tour we'll
talk about that and what we have going
on right after this it's some people
Town what David Wayne don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get into David Wayne and what
he's got going on Jason what do we have
you want to tell us uh we're doing
because this is gonna drop like right
away so we are doing our show tag it
which is really fun comedians come on do
their sets we are writing feverishly
jokes that are tags to their jokes that
we then pitch them at the end of their
set so collaborative audience with the
audience there it's really fun we're
doing on the 13th at The Comedy Store in
the belly room and then on the 18th
we're doing it at Largo with Patton and
Fortune feemster and two huge guests
that we are not allowed to announce
you're going to be very glad you're
there you still have like amazing shows
and I think we should all go yes let's
all go to those shows and if you're
listening to this after those you should
just go to superscores.com because you
probably have new dates for all dates
we're doing another tagging on October
uh 18th in a show at The Bourbon Room
and just good stuff all the way around
supersques.com uh we just did the middle
age dad jam band with David which was so
much fun we sat it's even a fun
Tick-Tock follow it is so fun it's great
where we sang a song We sang centerfold
by the J geils Band and we got to do our
joke at the beginning that Jay Giles is
the Jewish Mick Jagger it's not it's
more than a joke it's real it's your
show he's the juice Jagger and then that
of course means that Bob Dylan is the uh
non-practicing Jewish Peter Wolf where'd
you guys doing that where was it Dan
this was at the lodge room in Highland
Park which is unbelievable unreal yeah
it's a really fun show packed it was a
blast patch with people yeah the crowd
was so electric and hot the band it was
like going to see a rock concert like
what if you went to see a rock concert
and the comedy was as good as Wet Hot
American Summer like imagine that mixed
in can I put that quote on our news yes
you absolutely should so you went to see
a rock concert in wet Hot America you
never reminded us of it reminded us of
course of all of the lovely days of
doing Stella yeah so it had that same
energy feel and you're just getting I'm
funny friends together and everyone's
but and then adding the rock and roll
aspect to it makes it
a fantasy camera thing what I love most
about it is you guys got together and
jammed right and at some point which
happens with all like writers comedians
we should do that what if we somebody
said what if we and you and it didn't
die there's so many what if we use like
Rory and I have a hundred Waters but
this what if we is so good because they
love to follow through came like the
execution for us to actually execute
something yeah executed I mean it really
it's it's a thing of social media where
we just were posting Random clips for
fun and we got a lot of inquiries right
from that people can you come and do
this show here this and do it there it's
so great and now we're like it's evolved
really into a band with with an ongoing
group of guests and we're now we're
about to go to the Midwest I know so
you're going on tour you're going to be
in Ann Arbor Michigan Arbor in
mid-september we'll be in Ann Arbor
Cleveland Ohio Chicago and Minneapolis
unbelievable cities and like
unbelievable cities but you know please
if you know people or you are near there
come see us it's a really it's a total
great I'm going to tell you right now as
we performed in the show and then we did
you see us we were like stood in the way
on the side stage and we watched the
whole show it is so worth watching it is
so much I mean we literally performed we
were in it and then we became fans
watching it the whole time it is I
haven't seen the full show so is it sort
of like a comedy bit tied to a song not
exactly it's well first of all it's
called middle-aged dad Jam I love
m-a-d-j-b.com just whatever
um and uh it's a rock show it's a it's a
lot it's a two big sets of like
incredible songs from 60s 70s 80s yeah
uh like a really big fun and there's all
these different guest singers that come
up and are part of it and there's like
background singers and horn section and
strings and cello it's like an
incredible whole thing and then we do
banter like any band would do but we
probably do more of it and it's funnier
than normal the banter is and this is
where it's like the banter is like like
hilarious bits that you love from you
know wet hot but they're all brand new
bits that were written for this show
it's so fun and I hope you guys also do
some fast like if sketchfest or moon
tower did was actually oh really San
Francisco this past January amazing we
had a huge show there and it was really
that's where that's what sort of we're
like oh my God
and we've so far we've also been to the
whole East Coast lag we just did Denver
we're going back to New York to see
Winery we're going to be in Portland
it's it's just the best the best the
best the best I love it we have said out
loud I'm putting it on the show anytime
you need us
we will come back I'm sorry I can't do
it
you're in the heavy rotation list
nadjb.com and they have sweet merch the
madjb pink hat oh yeah dopest thing hot
hat your son was wearing his son plays
saxophone it's the coolest thing ever
you guys it just go see it that's all
and where can people see I know you post
clips of it on uh at your at Kevin Wayne
you can we have there's we have our own
Instagram in our own Tick Tock now right
and madjb.com is where you can there's a
mailing list there
um I'm doing a good job on this so far
right yeah can I be the host from now
yes of this show people Town yeah great
you are in one of your team you're in
the heavy Road I'd almost love to
replace you guys uh that'd be all three
of us I'm fine if you replace me because
you already have a scalar on the thing
there you go and I've got so much to do
so David will be here that Jason turns
and throws I would love David to be a
full-time uh no one comes in place like
David Wayne I'm just gonna say that I
come here to do the job that's right he
comes here and he makes work he makes
play his work and even if he showed up a
half an hour late like he did on Role
Models I mean I take my cue from Jim
Cameron I work hard and I play hard
I take my cue from Jim Cameron I don't
take myself too seriously I take my cue
from Jim Cameron when he says action
that's when I started when I make
something it's three hours that's right
you know are you ready I'm not even
going there all right I take a cue from
Jim Cameron I listen to other people's
opinions here we go sent in by Kyle
Spike Spicer Spiker is this story number
two this is Story number two TV Kyle at
TV Kyle
s-p-e-i-c-h-e-r Spicer spider Spiker
uh Jewish
speeches are coming over David oh yeah
put your good slacks on uh the woman
that ugly daughter
well they bring around they leave her in
the car but it's gonna be woman robs
Spring Hill bank with Nerf style gun
says she's joking according to death at
what point
yeah that's the key question at what
point if she if you walk in with a gun
and you're like I'm doing this as a joke
it's still about bad idea but right
right it's a little better yeah and it's
like if you're playing pickup basketball
and you put up a shot as someone hit you
and it misses you and then you
immediately call a foul every time you
file
knock knock who's there me with a gun me
with a gun who uh so it's probably like
a bright neon like me yeah a Nerf
although the ceiling I didn't see a
photo all right did she pull it over the
shoulder in a dramatic way that's a Nerf
gallon I know a guy this is a real story
when I was growing up a kid tried to
steal the bicycle from my backyard
garage and started running and some guy
was walking down the street and took out
his walkie-talkie and pointed at the kid
and said stop or I'll shoot and it
worked he stopped yeah
you don't want to find out you don't
wait you know which is why this is not a
good idea to do so it's bad uh okay
Hernando County Sheriff's Office said on
June 1st well we all remember where we
were on six months and also we know
Hernando County Sheriff they're not
messing around they put a statement out
it's just yes they responded to a bank
robbery at the Wells Fargo on Commercial
Way deputies said employees told them
that Vanessa Ortega will guess how old
she is later okay Enter the location
about 12 30 p.m which is bright blue
object this is afternoon yeah lunchtime
a bright blue object that appeared to be
a handgun right blue you got to take if
you've stopped it with a walkie-talkie
you got to treat it I hope she like shot
it off a couple times
they could be any color it could be any
color thank you that's right according
to the shares fortnite you would know
that I do play fortnite Ortega pointed
the object at the customers and Bank
staff before yelling I'm drunk this is a
robbery kid give me all your money I'm
I'm drunk first of all it's a hysterical
joke it's funny right yeah don't you get
it as a professional I can say give that
an A plus yeah you guys don't understand
it's not my fault yes look it might be
too smart for you guys this is like Andy
Kaufman way to read the room deputies
allege that Ortega even forced a
customer to give her all her money
saying put all your money in my envelope
is that a euphemism put all your money
in my envelope in uh in Amsterdam that's
what you said in the red light district
that's your I'm gonna go into this bank
and get everybody's money and I'm
bringing an envelope I would pay to
watch someone put money in someone else
even just it's always an awkward ability
to put it into it because yeah I got to
move wait the bills are almost as long
as you get it give me a second let me
stack these pills one will also
someone's got to open the sides of the
envelope and yes you gotta Maybe also
you have to make sure she might have
been sweating and accidentally sealed
the envelope that's right and then
you're in this place hold on I'm peeling
let me peel it let me let me because I
want to be you guys aren't even getting
this joke or maybe they'd lent her and
let her open her all right so wait
here's where I here's where I like the
sharper weapon here's where I think she
is actually being funny or she realized
it was a mistake however when she got to
the teller window Ortega said she was
only joking before withdrawing 500 from
her own account so she walks in yells to
everybody I'm here to rob it then gets
up to the teller I'm Joe no no she took
money from a woman she does everything
in the lobby area yeah it's up to the
counter hey I'm joking answer sir give
me 500 questions how much money did she
get from them but they let her continue
doing anything after she pointed a gun
at people I mean at this point everybody
wants to go along with the bed she
actually got a she got a cooler it was a
big yes and crime yes
it's right by the uh Florida I know when
this improv team goes to the bank and
that's when I'm going and that's they
can't stop me they can't say no yeah we
took that improv to the bank you guys
all right here we go the Sheriff's
Office can I get a suggestion from the
victims yes one word one word uh
sheriff's office said the bank staff
easily identified Ortega because she was
a regular at the bank is this a joke I
don't know if she's joking she went to
her bank her name is I think Jennifer
Vanessa Vanessa now that the details are
coming in I guess it feels like it
really was a joke it's a joke it's still
not a good joke but let's sauce up
Wednesdays a little bit but it is like
they know her like she this is like I
would love to see the the tape is she
like hey uh Andy how are the kids or
like the assistant manager Stephen who's
like Vanessa what are we doing here hey
hey Steve how's your son's soccer team I
need all your money all your money all
your money
is he doing t-ball JK JK although it's
maybe it's like at the airport where
they say you cannot even allow to joke
about it you can't joke about it no no
this is it no okay I'll probably on
reviewing surveillance video the
deputies also recognized Ortega from
previous interactions yes well was she
there like a week ago opening up a 529
like also like someone who goes to the
bank in these days yeah if you're in
your bank a lot then that says a lot
about you you don't need to be in your
bank I don't think I've set foot in a
bank in years ages it's all done all my
money if I have to I all my money is
under my mattress growing up though in
the 70s I remember I would go with my
mother to the bank all the day and get a
lollipop to do yeah I don't know what
she needed to do there do you would you
go to the drive-through in the bank
where they had the thing you stick oh I
loved it yeah it was so fun
and then they'd send back the lollipop
in the return there are still buildings
that use those vacuum tube message
systems and they're like there's new
tech companies that do it as sort of a
retro cool thing I actually think that's
really cool yeah yeah like I'm waiting
for a coffee place to like do it and
could not do it in a coffee place no I
think I have seen a couple of food I
have seen like some cool restaurants
where they they're doing like weird
third you know techie it must be a Ohio
thing uh in addition to the bank robbery
called okay deputies also got a call
about a verbal disturbance at another
place so she's she's on a rampage her
for that too I think so that's maybe
address new material you know how many
sets she got in that day I know she's
like just working
what is she doing in the Sky Zone maybe
she's just so so bored yeah she's like I
gotta I gotta do some jokes come on uh
the Sheriff's Office learned that Ortega
was also involved in that disturbance of
course she was yeah this is her day and
also when you say it in the story it's
gonna mean it's going to be her right it
turns out that disturbance was a
completely other person don't know why
we wrote this in the story uh we've had
those we have had those they were close
they need to fill like a thousand isn't
it weird that these two disturbances
were so close but Mike also the air
conditioning stopped working at the
sheriff's office
and we fixed that pothole over on seven
and you know your cousin we don't know
our cousin Steve okay Detectives said
after taking Ortega into custody she
admitted to yelling about the robbery
while wielding a Nerf style toy gun
which he said she uses for her own
protection what okay okay
she Twisted it again it's like a David
she keeps burying her so but
how did she say it if she said in a
really sorry which I used for my own
protection was she winking when she said
it right that's my question also against
two because if it's eight-year-olds they
will run from a Nerf gun that's a
protection situation protecting yourself
from Neighbors kids that might be trying
to come after you didn't say that's the
end of it all right here's room I bet
the guy who stole your bike would have
stopped if someone would have pointed a
nurse maybe she uses it to tie the her
n95 mask together so it's that kind of
protects 100 right that's what it's
projecting you from different things
yeah or she shoots condoms onto her
partner's penis it penis that's if true
that's a great it's P9 and that's a
great trick right because that is then
it is her for her protection but it's
like damn perfect it takes forever
because her Tick Tock account is one of
those trick shot things yeah and so
that's a whole part of it as well like
dude it's not trick shots they're called
Dick shots either people throw cards
into like yeah CD player this is condom
on the dick yes
one time it's like and then uh all right
how old let's let's get out of here
27. straight up that's he didn't even
hesitate a woman who was joking about a
gun has a Nerf gun says it's for
protection but also you want to go 41 41
27 54. 54 years old I thought you'd go
young she's our age get your answers in
shot at your ham radios wherever you are
okay Vanessa Ortega is 31 years old wow
do I get macaroni uh you do yeah you get
25 more people showing up to the Ann
Arbor show and then Minneapolis and
Chicago and then Cleveland m
we're gonna hear in segment three
um an athlete loses a race in the worst
way possible I love it you got more
dumping I'm looking forward to segment
three I am not tuning away he's not he's
gonna stay here with us Dave's gonna
stay with us for Segment three it's dumb
people down with David Wayne we'll be
right back
hey guys I'm so excited about this
sponsor Jay because all three of us are
huge sports fans I love that prize picks
has decided to sponsor a major cast
because it's really so simple to play
prize picks I can make my picks and
submit my entry in less than 60 seconds
and it is just a blast quick withdrawals
easy gameplay and an enormous selection
of players and Stat types are what makes
prize picks the number one daily fantasy
sports app so I'm excited to do it
because obviously we're on the precipice
of the NFL season and I've done a lot of
research about specific players for my
fantasy league it's like so fun because
it's just your player against the
numbers and easy and it makes uh your
Sunday that much more enjoyable oh yeah
yes great so where can they go here's
the deal guys go to prize picks.com DPT
and use the code DPT for for a first
deposit match of up to 100
creditspicks.com slash DPT use the code
DPT for a first deposit match of up to
100 don't for forget this promo code
lower case right price picks daily
fantasy sports Made Easy friends townies
Helix sleep is what you need ran I can
tell you that I got a helix mattress for
my daughter it is unbelievable I'm
loving mine so off they have so many
different types of matches the lineup
offers 20 Elite and unique mattresses
you got from the Luxe collection Lux
collection is so good the newly released
Helix the elite collection of mattress
designed for Big and Tall sleepers if
you are that even matches made for just
kids I got a full size mattress for my
daughter because she's redoing her room
and now I'm telling you she's like get
out of my bed get out of my bed I'm like
no I love you
but you know what I like is the Sleep
quiz that they have you take you it lets
you know what your mattress work what
mattress will work best for your body
you take the Sleep quiz I did it you
find your perfect mattress in under two
minutes and your personalized mattress
is shipped straight to your door free of
charge so they ship to the door very
easy I got it there and it was very easy
the way it's packaged is perfect the two
pillows that I got were amazing and
incredible so we redid this thing for my
daughter redoing her room and her
mattress is her favorite thing in there
so thank you here's something everybody
should know too Helix knows there's no
better way to test out a mattress than
by sleeping on it in your own home
that's why they offer a 100 night trial
and a 10 to 15 year warranty to try your
new Helix mattress they say it takes
about 30 days to get used to a mattress
they went over triple that to give you
the time to realize awarded number one
mattress picked by G Q and Wired
Magazine uh even recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors sleep
medicine look it's a go-to solution for
improving your sleep I'm gonna tell you
something Helix is offering 20 off all
mattresses and the two free pillows
they're great it's a great deal go to
helixsleep.com DPT use the code Helix
partner20 this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long guys with Helix
with Helix better sleep starts now we
got it hey guys want to talk to you
about our sponsor and they're one of our
favorite sponsors because they're
friends of ours and it's a business that
Randy and I were patrons of we actually
like bought clothes there before they
became our sponsor we love these guys
from the beginning
they craft clothes that feel as good as
a day at the beach as we said before
they craft clothes that just feel
comfortable they have a guarantee they
stand behind everything they make a
hundred percent it's amazing design Dan
you just met them yeah I met Alex I was
at the Newport uh Folk Festival and Alex
was there Fair already had like a pop-up
incredible there's not many times when
we get to say hey here's our experience
with the owner of brand that we believe
in and is also a sponsor of this show
this guy couldn't have been greater the
quality and the clothes that they make
it's one thing to have something that's
going to last for a long time it's
another thing to have it be stylish and
comfortable and love it they're just the
best Jay you just got the beach flannel
and I just got the movement chinos some
of the best pants I've ever had that
flannel looks so good on you it's what
my family gives me for Father's Day Dan
tell them about the legend okay so the
legend sweatshirt here's what here's
what they say here's what I can't wait
to experience say goodbye to your dad's
stiff and rough flannels the legend
sweatshirt boasts a unique Airy
lightness married to an unparalleled
comfort of stretch it's never been seen
before in a flannel it feels like you're
wearing your favorite broken in sweater
I have five of them I have five of them
I have four Legends and I have the
legend sweatpants and I have the Legends
I'm ordering mine today dude it's the
best because it looks like a flannel but
it stretches like you're inside they say
the legend sweater shirt is made with 95
lower impact fibers guys I'm speaking
words I don't understand
less fossil fuel uh combustion lower CO2
image as a result it's so comfortable
it's super durable it lasts I've had
mine for five six years is it too early
to say I'm getting somebody a Christmas
gift
I'm getting me one yeah ball gift a
Halloween gift do it done guess what
Verdi is giving all you dumb people Town
listeners an amazing deal 20 off your
first art order here's what you do head
to faradaybrand.com DPT use the code DPT
at checkout that's
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com DPT
stick around make a sound there's more
than people Town hey guys welcome back
to the show before we jump into the
final story and Daniel Van Kirk takes us
home Dan uh where can people see you I
know you have something really big
coming up on 11 11. on 11 11 I'm
shooting my special two shows in Chicago
at the Lincoln Lodge go to
danielvankirk.com for those tickets the
night before I'm headlining my hometown
in Rochelle and between when we are
recording this and then I will be all
over the Midwest I'm uh uh opening night
of 10 000 laughs in Minneapolis
in Boston I'm headlining hilarities in
Cleveland busy I'm working on it so
there's so many students so many cities
Midwest south uh there's our Buddy Hayes
has a great place in Raleigh I've never
played Raleigh and great they have the
Rialto Theater that's on a Saturday
night the 14th there's tons of stuff go
to
danielvankirk.com and if you know
anything about WordPress let me know fix
my site question when you go on these
gigs do you go and hang out and have a
drink after or you're like I did my work
or I'd get out of there I love it all
I will say to people where's a great bar
with a shuffleboard so you meet people
you're more than welcome
to the people and you know it's because
of covid I did a whole bunch of like
digital shows because I felt we were
doing stand-up on for nobody in the room
and um I got to know a lot of fans of
this podcast fans of mine fans of uh
cool people town I'm sorry a pen pals
common support and so yeah if they come
out to the show if I see a Kevin
Harrington in uh in New Orleans or an
Elise LeBlanc in New England I will say
like hey let's go where you guys going
let's go somewhere that's so cool I also
think on this tour I might on Sunday
morning say is anybody with the Sunday
Ticket watching the Bears game and I'll
just go walk or find a good bar
absolutely should you were going to ask
can I plug one more thing yes please I
have this sketch comedy trip called the
state I really remember that amazing
sketch comedy group from the 90s and
it's it's myself and Carrie Kenny and
Tomlin and Camarino and Juliet trulio
and Michael lean black Etc and we are
are on tour
uh now yeah and we're about to announce
it but I'm just giving you a little yeah
we've got three shows coming up in New
York City uh in mid-october and then we
are going to be making some
announcements about Los Angeles and um
San Francisco and Boston wow and we're
all over it I love it to get 10 people
out to go on the road that's insane yeah
we just did uh our first show in Denver
and it was insane will Kevin Allison be
at the Paramount Theater oh yeah Kevin
Allison wonderful Kevin uh sentimental
thing
a whole lot of pudding it was one of the
first bits I ever copied before you know
about making your own stuff oh wow and I
would always do it for my mom and my
stepdad and I and he passed away uh
shortly after I would like to that bit
and
um because my mom would uh whenever she
wanted a good laugh and to think of him
would be like do it again dude I would
do the whole both both characters the
whole bit where'd you get all that
pudding it was so wow you guys love this
stuff beautiful my son I'm gonna dip my
balls in it and porcupine racetrack are
you are you doing porcupine it's a fan
favorite fan favorite old and new
material but it's a great show and Teddy
Shapiro porcupine all the all the
favorites are involved great helmets are
you ready for story three friends two
story three and take us I don't know if
you talked about this in cheap seats if
you did fire up those jokes again
because I guarantee you have them
athlete loses race and Colombia sent in
by Ace of Finance at dragon ilm in an
unfortunate turn of events an athlete
lost the 400 meter at the 2022 World
Olympics the u-20 Championships due to a
wardrobe malfunction so he ran out of
his shorts literally what 18 year old
was it Lenny Kravitz Alberto that so
it's under 20. that's that using
miltonborough hey Twitter Alberto
who hails from Italy was competing at
the 400 meter decathlon in Columbia oh
the Italian this was on purpose yeah
this is totally on purpose yes he's
trying to get your girlfriend
my penis
extremely well gaining Pace against his
competitors leaving the bystanders and
the impression that he might win the
race with with ease however after no
nino passed the Middle Lane he looked
uncomfortable and kept reaching down to
hold his crotch a couple of times at the
time viewers did not know what went
wrong but no Nino's Pace decreased a bit
allowing competitors to overtake him as
per I don't know what this is Led sports
or somebody I don't know yeah it says
David Sanchez de Castro great name
reported that his penis kept falling out
of his shorts so as he wanted this to
happen he he's like I'm not going to win
this race but I need I need everyone to
know that goes on stage and he's like
you know so this is a picture of the
race you could see him here in blue with
his hand so he keeps not to flopping out
not to be attracted wear briefs or boxer
briefs
compression shorts I can tell you I
cannot sure relate to this I it has
nothing to do with having a big [__]
which I don't know but it has to do here
in Good Company yeah but like if you
just sometimes I grab like the wrong
shorts to play tennis or something and
they're they're just the elastic has
worn out too much yeah too much and then
suddenly I have to readjust every two
seconds yes because your balls are real
snuggly you're not you're not in it also
though shouldn't you have a team
specified uniform that is like we will
put this in your locker if you're in the
world championships you should be
breaking out a new pair of shorts for
your or at least checking them yes you
should have three oh you know what these
are the shorts I use to clean my garage
it's so stupid it's a rag I brought the
rag it is you know you're taking it to
real life stuff it is horrible when you
find yourself doing some sort of like
manual chore for your home and realize
you should have changed your shirt
before you started this right but by
that point you're already in that sweat
and you're like why did I decide to
start moving things around the garage in
this outfit in a button yeah it is
horrible I feel like though I have to
say say this and it's probably going to
be something I regret but it reminded me
as you started to read that story about
my friend Stuart Plummer and I when we
were maybe five used to make a lot of
fake radio reports on the radio shack
tape recorder in my bathroom of course
you did and we would be like and in
Sporting News Henry mishkamas won the
race but there was something wrong about
it he won it with his penis
okay so if he's running if you and he's
Annie is erect you could win by a head
that's what I literally yeah but why you
would be hips first would be a very odd
way to write well I just last week I
went to that race they had of all the
vegetables did you see that no well the
lettuce was ahead
[Music]
was trying to catch up
if there's any other reports David is a
family show Dave no but it was a it was
a good race the incident did not allow
him to run properly during the race the
18 year old athlete did try to tackle
the issue but nothing worked in his
favor at the moment unfortunately he
finished last with a time of now this is
a first sweeter ladies
how long do you think it took him to
finish so I'm a track dad I can 20
minutes remember you are
uh finish the race I should have said to
finish the race yeah yeah you attracted
too this is the 2022 World Athletics
under 20 championships okay so he's made
it through they've made it through 400
times so good so just to strap laid out
I just he's dick adjusting 42 42 seconds
is a good 400 time 43 seconds uh I would
say yes at the world yeah yes 43
so what do you think he's doing with a
constant adjustment which is messing up
his stride 48 48 what are you David
doing
a minute 20. I'm gonna say 55 seconds 55
yeah can I also say if you guys haven't
done this on cheap seats we haven't do
it anyway because you could do it with
the video it'll be hilarious because
you'll probably be like oh he's starting
to lose it okay yeah
with a time of
51.5 wow that's still so fast
two yeah well in the picture there's
five or six people all right
I mean he didn't have to finish you know
finish himself you know regardless I
salute him for getting to the finals and
for participating and finishing and just
for being a good Sportsman yeah I mean
well like three women helped like you
know how rare is it that a man lets
someone else Finish First folks I'm out
of here he's opposite have you guys
heard of have you guys heard of The
Impossible mile it's a workout like a
crazy workout thing that people eat like
three impossible Burgers you get you go
to a track it's 400 meters of burpees oh
then 400 meters of lunges oh no then 400
meters of Bear Cross and then a 400
meter run I'd be done after one meter of
Burpee they say that when you get they
say that when you get to the 400 meter
run it feels so easy yeah of course
because you've already done all this
stuff the idea of running you're like
yeah I'll do this simple yeah when I was
in my 20s I did like a mini try I'm in
my 30s now I did this
mini Triathlon in Brooklyn I remember
that the swimming and the biking was so
so hard yeah to the running it was like
yes you know they have one here I do it
at the Rose Bowl and it's a reverse they
call it a Sprint like a mini you swim at
the Rose Bowl pool you do at the end you
start with the run and you go one time
around the Rose Bowl and that uh Golf
Course mentally because it's only one
lap it feels way better but it is a 5K
but it feels like you're I'm only doing
this once yeah then you go to the bikes
you go to your bike station and you do
your bike same thing three times which
feels way easier than the run you just
did sure and then you go back drop your
bike at the bike station run over to the
Pasadena Aquatic Center and you do down
back down and when you come out that's
the Finish but it's it is like it's
challenging for us but it's not undoable
sounds fun it is actually I would do
that Dan when is it it's the second
weekend of March
one could just do that any day you
really actually could let's go today
let's just do it okay
we gotta get back to work we gotta you
guys David Wayne thank you for joining
us on the show and everybody goes live
go see uh the middle age dad jam band
Live which is so fun who knows maybe
when they're back in L.A we might pop up
again on this davidwain.com go to
superstars.com
enjoy all that and oh [__] we got to get
back to work everybody
[Music]